they're your sac leaders since 2012 oh
and
two of them are now teammates with the
arizona cardinals chandler jones 97 jj
watt 95.5
we are drafting the best current pass
rush tandems in honor of the watt
signing by arizona and chris
the one thing i learned as i scoured
through the depth charts and the rosters
preparing
a list of potential tandems to select
there's a lot of pass rushers that are
free agents i know
yes yes it's not making this easy and
and and so we're not
including them we're free agents
who knows where they're going to land so
they're not part of this which makes it
harder to do all right you got the
trivia question oh that's right
on me all right sorry hold on let me
open up my phone and read this here we
go live
tv here we go okay i can't remember what
it was they told me i got to do but i
just want to make sure
four vikings four vikings your team
[Music]
okay have led uh the league in sacks
how many can you name there's four how
many can you name we already talked
about one today during jared allen right
allen no brainer okay jared allen
thank you you should get three stallman
yes chris dolman right
on keith millard keith millard
[Music]
come on he didn't lead the league no
randall yes john randall
yep all right we'll give you there's one
more who was the fourth one doug martin
carl aller doug martin yeah wow doug
martin 1982
the first year sacks were recorded they
didn't have sex
during the days of the purple people
leaders although between eller and
marshall and paige
they may have deluded each other as they
crushed the quarterback all right i got
three out of four i got a good job
and uh let's see here i gotta go back to
my my cheat sheet
uh i will go with and this can be any
tandem
i guess i'll go khalil mack and robert
quinn chicago bears neither of them is
gonna be free agents this year so uh
yeah khalil mack could be traded in
theory to the seahawks but for now
for now he's still a bear khalil mack
robert quinn
with with a a heavy skewing toward
khalil mack yeah definitely i mean
robert quinn was one of the more
you know the one of the bigger
disappointments in all of football last
year i mean they threw out a lot of
money
you know let leonard floyd go to the
rams who had an
unbelievable year and they didn't quite
get the investment return with
uh robert quinn so a good one by you
mack is still
a phenomenal football player uh to your
point all right
i mean i'm gonna go with the steelers
all right because they got three guys so
tj watt and you can put twoit or hayward
there
whatever one you want i mean two had
gotten more sacks last year
with his 11 so let's just say him for
now i don't think he's as good as a
player as cam hayward at this point of
his career
but i'll go with those two they give a
little leeway it's really a trio in
pittsburgh which is
pretty unbelievable uh but yeah i'll
pick the steelers to to start it off
they got so many guys that you could put
on a list of tandems i mean you know
but dupree example of a guy that we're
not going to include in that's because
he's due to be a free agent it would
have been watt and dupree but you can
pivot to others and i think we've done
this before where we've had multiple
selections from the steelers
right with different guys involved in it
all right if we're going to start mixing
and matching
defensive ends and defensive tackles
i'll go frank clark and chris jones
city chiefs right i'm with you i i had
them written down i mean
we with the free agent status like you
talked about we i think we're gonna have
to pick some defensive tackles in these
guys right
and chris jones you know to what you're
saying and first off i agree i mean
you look at a lot of passing situations
they will move him out to defense to end
and
you know he'll stunt inside or maybe
just pass rush from there and do that
type of stuff so
uh yeah i got i got no issue with with
you taking that pic right there
all right um i gotta go
to the the football team you know i
don't care what the stats look like this
year
first off i just chase young with
anybody all right
i mean literally you can put you over
there and i think they're in the
discussion for like one of the best
pass rushing tandems uh but you know
him with montez sweat i believe kerrigan
is a free agent right i'm trying to
remember here it's i guess
90 million names in my head but yeah
i'll go with him
and montez sweat but a little like we
just talked about the steelers
you know you could go deron payne or
jonathan allen or any of them
but to me that's got a chance to be a
very very special a little bit more
maybe a projection pick
for coming up this year uh montez sweat
is a freak of nature like chase young
not to that extent but both are you know
greek gods in that aspect
since we didn't call this the chandler
jones and jj watt memorial draft i'll
just go with those yeah
even though it's a projection and you
hope that jj watts stays healthy but
i i'm sufficiently influenced by the
fact that they now have the two
highest sac total leaders since 2012 on
the same team and i think the presence
of jones makes it easier for watt the
presence of watt could make it easier
for jones
agreed agreed definitely i think that
could be
a hell of a tandem i wouldn't be shocked
to see them wrecking havoc
and and rican have is it wreaking havoc
or wrecking habits
yes right well either way it's havoc
okay and
as in as in as in your closed reek of
marijuana
that happens at times not that that not
that i'm talking about you not lately
but
uh it it will be soon we're almost out
of that detox phase we're gonna get back
into it here real soon
uh but i'm i'm i'm with you there that
was one i had written down to i was kind
of hoping you might forget about that
but that's
that's a damn good one i think that has
potential all right and my last pick i'm
a little stuck here
you know because i'm really down to like
the 49ers and the packers
you know the 49ers of course both are
coming back they do have armstead
and they're another team you can get
into some other guys they got there
the packers zadarius and preston or
zadarius and rashawn gary i'm going to
go to the 49ers sean garrett rashawn
gary's ahead of preston smith on the
deputy i know i think preston smith's
going to get cut
i think so too it was an underwhelming
year he kind of disappeared this year
after that first good year
and i'm with you you know they got a guy
there to replace him i'm going to go to
the 49ers though because nick bosa
you know getting hurt early on in the
year last year we know he's a psycho
with working out and doing all that
i expect him to be close to 100 to start
the year and then
eric armstead hey sack production wood
production whatever he's still a force
he's a giant human being who can do
everything on the defensive line so i'll
go with those two
uh as my last my last pick there i was
gonna get sneaky and say bradley chubb
and von miller but
miller's status is too tenuous yeah i
was right i was wondering whether you
would
i think they're going to cut him i think
so even though he's not due to be a free
agent
he's not going to be on the team this
year and maybe it'll be miles garrett
and von miller when we do this draft
in august because and that's another
reason why if i'm the cardinals and
maybe they've fully explored
the wormhole that would be whether there
was someone else out there that they
should have waited for
but i think some of these teams were
waiting to see what happened with von
miller and maybe there's an indication
behind the scenes what's going to happen
but uh between von miller and j.j watt
which guy would you want when you
consider the fact that
von miller missed all of last year yeah
it's a little scary too
you know not and he's you know not a a
giant drafted the same year
yeah the same year he's truly an edge
guy
um that's a close one it really is but i
guess i'd take j.j
watt right now just because that's a
pretty serious injury and things that
you know von miller's had to deal with
uh let alone it seems like there's some
off the field things that are yet to be
figured out here
that is interesting but yeah i know some
vague
thing that was referred to the district
attorney and no one will say what it is
and yeah i would want to know everything
there is to know about that before i do
business with vaughn miller just
so i know whether or not i'm going to
have him on the field out of all the
ones we
picked right like which ones like you
know excites you the most like i'm very
excited about the montes sweat chase
young one like that to me
can be like one of those where we could
look back and be like holy crap it's
like a
it's the eagles in their heyday type
pass rush and those type of things
i mean which one excites you the most
well sweat's intriguing because
there were teams that loved him in the
2019 draft but there was that weird
heart thing that popped up at the
combine
and and you know some of these teams was
like sorry that's enough to be off our
board we're not messing with that even
though we think the player is a stud
stud and i know there were teams in the
first round that felt that way
washington obviously didn't they traded
back into the round to get him
so i think that's got potential you know
we didn't mention demarcus lawrence and
randy
yeah gregory finally got reinstated last
year and he had his moments the problem
is demarcus lawrence has been
disappointed he signed his long-term
deal
that's it it's just it's been a little
underwhelming and i can't put my name to
randy gregory quite yet or do that but
yeah you're right
i mean he popped he definitely did and
they have the potential to be something
here going into the year two to where
you go oh if they you know everything
aligns right
watch out for them but uh yeah that's an
interesting position in the nfl as
pertains to free agency because of
course jpp and shaq buret
shaq barrett would be uh right up there
at the top of the list with what they
can do and i do expect shaq barrett to
be back with the bucks but we don't know
that yet
and you know the one team that i tried i
looked i scanned
i the vikings known for that defense
known for that pass rush for all those
years
with dalia hunter missing all of last
season we don't know what his health is
who knows what that pass rush is going
to be in minnesota
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights
from nbc sports